bonsoir merci d'être avec nous c'est
donc la fin de l'union sacrée entre
félix chick et tshisekedi et l'ancien
président kabila une décision
unilatérale selon vous en tout cas il
faut dire que la déclaration du
président de la république à l'issue des
consultations politiques il a dirigé
depuis entre le 2 et le 25 novembre à
lançant officiellement ce dimanche 6
décembre dernier l'union sacrée consacré
donc la fin de la coalition fcc cash
c'est une décision effectivement
unilatérale
parce qu'il l'a prise sans avoir
consulté son successeur le président
honoraire joseph kabila et c'est ça qui
est d'ailleurs le partisan des joseph
kabila dénoncer et ils ont dit prendre
acte de cette décision du président
tshisekedi et donc il assume désormais
la cohabitation de ces quais rachète le
temps du président félix tshisekedi
nécessaire pour trouver retrouver une
nouvelle majorité en tous cas il faut
dire que la situation est elle est un
peu volatil et confie ce d'autant plus
que hier lundi il ya eu des troubles à
l'assemblée nationale tout simplement
parce que la présidente l'actuelle
présidente qui dirige la chambre basse
du parlement congolais est lady condé
joseph kabila elle avait convoqué une
plénière et le partisan des flux
tshisekedi ont tout fait pour empêcher
la tenue de cette plénière c'est comme
ça qu'ils aillent la bagarre au sein de
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale est
aujourd'hui donc c'est mardi le
pétitionnaire donc le groupe des félix
ce qu'elle dit les députés qui sont avec
felice qui avait initié des pétitions
qui visait chaque membre du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale
et ces pétitions ont été déposés dans
des conditions 1 p
compliqué et ils ont convoqué une
plénière qui devait se tenir aujourd'hui
donc le pétitionnaire
la présidente actuelle de l'assemblée
nationale a aussi convoqué plénière qui
devait se tenir aujourd'hui le des
partis se sont retrouvés ensemble dans
le mythique
ils se sont affrontés et finalement la
police est intervenue et ce n'est que le
les camps du président si c'était des
qui a pu se réunir et installé un
nouveau bureau qui va examiner le jeudi
10 décembre là le pétition contre le le
dire aux actuels teny par le pro kabila
mais il faut dire que rien n'assure que
le président tu sais qu'elle y arrivera
à faire basculer la majorité
parlementaire
il faudrait donc attendre voir le vote
qui va se passer le jeudi dans le cadre
de l'examen de pétition qui vise le
membre du bureau actuel de l'assemblée
nationale alors une dernière question on
a vu les réactions à la joie à la fois
de joie et de colère est ce qu'on peut
craindre une crise politique qui
pourrait durer l'onu d'ailleurs sont
donc s'en inquiète
on est déjà en pleine crise on est vous
compris vous savez la situation comme
elle est très volatile on a déjà des
problèmes sécuritaires dans la partie
est du pays on a le problème aujourd'hui
économique avec la crise dit coronavirus
on a aujourd'hui les problèmes de
légitimité qui est toujours évoqué parce
qu'il faut dire que là le résultat de
l'élection du 30 décembre 2018 est
toujours contestée par un des candidats
les candidats martin fayulu qui
réclament toujours la victoire la lettre
à l'élection présidentielle donc il ya
déjà cette crise de légitimité qui
existe et puis à cette crise il ya
maintenant sept prises entre la
coalition au pouvoir donc le président
tshisekedi et son ex son ancien
partenaire joseph kabila et puis le
président tshisekedi pour en arriver là
il a fait alliance assez cuillère et 2
opposant du président kabila g site ici
moïse katumbi et jean pierre bemba
donc on est vraiment des gens en pleine
crise s'il des parties n'agissent pas
avec sagesse il ya en tout cas risque et
beaucoup des craintes que la situation
s'empire davantage
merci stanis bouge acquerra tshiamala
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france